-Thank you so much.
You gave me this earlier today,
and I´m really happy --
What am I wearing from
the Whoopi line?
-Short of wearing, you know,
Elf on a Shelf
and Mensch on a Bench.
-Yeah, there you go.
That´s wonderful. Thank you.
-Which is actually a doll that
somebody made
a couple of years ago.
And I just thought,
"Well, they should meet."
-So, but this is
a passion of yours.
-Yes.
-Holiday sweaters.
-You do not like them
to be called --
You do not believe
these are ugly holiday sweaters.
-No. I do believe they´re -- I
call them ugly holiday sweaters,
and people keep saying,
"No, they´re not.
They´re really great."
And I said, "Okay.
Whatever you like.
They´re just holiday sweaters."
-And do these help you --
Do you find this helps you
with the holiday spirit?
-No. You know what?
I always have
the holiday spirit,
because when I was a kid,
my mother made them magical.
And so I was raised
to believe that children
should have the holidays
to be children.
They can be --
You know, you can mess them up
any other time of the year,
but never during the holidays.
-How did your mother
go about making it magical?
What would she do?
-Well, so, you´d go to bed.
My brother and I had --
I had an older brother.
And, so, we´d go to sleep
and we would wake up.
And, in the old days,
there was this pink stuff
that used to clean windows,
but every holiday season,
they would give you stencils.
So, you´d stencil, like,
a Christmas tree or
Christmas balls or whatever.
And we´d wake up,
and there would be,
like, stuff on the windows.
And she would never say
anything about it.
It was just, "Ooh!
Stuff is happening."
And then, like,
a tree would appear.
And then, the next day,
there would be
a couple things on the tree.
And then there would be some
tinsel on the tree.
And, so, up until Christmas Eve,
the tree got done,
and she never said a word.
It was like
it happened magically.
-Oh, wow. So you never saw
her doing any of it.
-You never saw her doing it.
And she would never say, "Oh,
what do you think of the tree?"
She would just --
Everything that your mother
would be doing normally,
she would be doing.
And we would be like,
"What happened?!"
How did this --"
Because, you know,
I grew up in the projects,
so there was no chimney, okay?
-Oh, yeah.
-Yeah.
-So when something gets
added to the tree,
it means someone broke
into the apartment, yeah.
-So, we then would go to sleep,
and it would be barren.
It was just no toys or anything.
And, man, we´d wake up
the next day,
and I don´t know
where she hid everything.
I don´t know how she did it,
´cause she was
a really hard-working woman.
But we had Christmas
like we were
the wealthiest people
in the world as kids.
And I just think
that when someone --
a parent or whoever the
person is that´s raising you --
wants to make it
so much fun that you just --
you never forget that feeling,
you know, that smell,
for me turkey,
and the smell of
the tree on Christmas morning.
So, these are just meant to make
you smile and think,
"Hey, you know what?
Good times are coming."
It´s hard.
You know, it´s hard
to keep chipper.
But I think you have to
keep chipper for the kids.
-Yeah.
-You deserve --
Kids deserve a better time,
sometimes, than we give them.
And I just --
I think holidays do that.
And it doesn´t matter
what you celebrate.
You know, I´m trying
to hit everybody
who´s celebrating
a holiday so that
when we say "happy holidays" --
You know, you don´t walk up
and say, "Hey, are you Jewish?
Happy Hanukkah.
No. You say, "Happy holidays,
´cause I don´t know
what you like."
-Yeah.
-I don´t know what you like.
I don´t know what you celebrate,
but happy whatever."
So instead of saying
"happy whatever,"
you say "happy holidays,"
which is nice.
-It´s nice.
It´s nice to cover everybody.
-I think so.